So even though something like the square root of 2 can't be simplified, some
other square roots can. So let's figure out if we can simplify roots and how to
do that. We'll start with this one. We're going to use the product rule to help
us simplify this radical. The product rule allows us to breakup a radical into
the multiplication of two separate radicals. So when we have two factors
multiply together underneath the radical. We can take the square root of each
of them and multiply that result together. For example for the square root of
100, we know this is really just 10. But we can find this answer another way.
We know 100 is the same thing as 4 times 25. So we can break up this radical
and take the square root of each of the factors. The square root of 4 is 2, and
the square root of 25 is 5, which leaves us with 2 times 5, which is 10, our
original answer. And these were perfect squares, so we were able to take out a
factor in each case, the 2 and the 5. You'll notice that 75 is not a perfect
square, but there is a perfect square as one of its factors. Use the product
rule to break this up into 2 radicals, and then take the square root of one of
them. Leave any numbers that are not perfect squares, underneath the radical.
When you're ready, write your answer here.